أوه ، هناك سيارة محترقة هناك ،
لذا هنا يمكنك أن ترى كيف تحترق هذه السيارات ،
دعني أحاول تكبير الصورة أكثر قليلاً
هناك الإطارات تحترق البذور
تحترق الورنيش بالطبع يحترق
هناك نوع من الأسلاك الرفيعة المتبقية
في الإطارات في النهاية وسيحترق
معدن الهيكل وأشياء أخرى
حتى لو
تذوب الزجاج في العديد من
السيارات المحترقة الأخرى التي رأيناها ،
وهذا أمر مثير للصدمة وبالطبع
عمود الكهرباء هناك  تحترق أيضًا
مشكلة واحدة هي أن الكهرباء
لا تزال قائمة ،
لذا
لا يزال هناك
تيار على الأسلاك وهذا يعني أن
هذا أمر خطير بعض الشيء وأيضًا
عندما يحترقون شبكة الكهرباء
تعاني بشكل كبير لذا فإن
عمال البناء
يحاولون الحفاظ على الشبكة  على قيد الحياة ، لكن آه
الأمر صعب بشكل متزايد في هذه
المرحلة ، لذا إذا استمرت الحمم البركانية ، فإن هذا
المنزل الأحمر للأسف لم يتبق منه سوى عمر قصير
، ولا
يسعنا إلا أن نأمل ألا تستمر الحمم البركانية
على
الإطلاق.  معدل ous ونأمل أن نتوقف
هنا ولكن آه حسنًا ، بالطبع ليس هناك
يقين من أن شجرة النخيل
هذه غارقة في الحمم البركانية الآن
متحصنة بالكامل
فيها وأتوقع أن
هذا لن يجعلها على الأرجح لذا
ها هي شجيرة صغيرة هذا فقط  اشتعلت
النيران هنا
ولكن حان الوقت الآن للتراجع
عن هذه المنطقة علينا ترك
هذا للحمم البركانية